patty is with us in winston-salem North
Carolina hi Patti how are you oh hi how
are you good welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show how can I help out I have a
question I was just wondering how much
do you financially help your adult
children without I know you know you can
help them son but without becoming in an
abler not it's not an amount
it's how they are acting right so when
are you on it when are you an enabler
I love they've been married for a number
of years and in those years they've made
very bad decisions and wasteful spending
and if you're giving them money you're
giving a drunk a drink exactly I know
we've even helped them to keep from
losing their house you know if it were
the two of them it wouldn't be bad but
there's a number of grandchildren well I
like the grandkids will survive if the
kids are hyper kids are hungry tell them
come over you'll feed them exactly yeah
that's that's that's a grandma that's a
grandmother guilt trip crap is what that
is well that's okay that's it because
you know my husband and I are retired
and I feel guilty that we are spending
our money doing things that we've saved
all our life for you you should not be
giving them money listen you're not
helping someone if you're participating
in their insanity right you're helping
someone if they have changed their ways
now let's pretend that the same young
couple that is your kids that let's
pretend that suddenly they started doing
a good job handling their money and they
were on a budget and they were making
wise choices and they were working extra
jobs and they were selling off stuff to
try to get out of debt in and then you
gave them some money to pay off one of
their debts well that would be helping
them right because they're heading in
the right direction but when someone's
heading in the wrong direction and you
help them that's not help
that's harm right right yeah I know and
there comes a time when you have to use
that tough love it's not tough love it's
just love hey that's true because when
you when you only assist someone in
harming themselves that's not in love
right
that's toxic garbage so when I come to
you and say you know we're getting ready
to lose our house you need to sell it
honey before you lose it and you guys
are going to have to sit down and figure
out what's been going on in your lives
and will coach you will even pay for you
to go to the Financial Peace University
class so you can learn how to handle
money but you guys can't keep handling
the money the way you've been handling
it right well you know what they
actually did take your class and they
actually did pay for it themselves
because they said if they paid for it
they knew that they would use it and
they didn't ever exactly yeah they know
max or they float right they they
actually enable each other
whatever one watch you know they they're
both the same yeah how old are they and
their early thirties okay and you're
talking about out you're your son-in-law
daughter-in-law and son or daughter
right if my daughter and son Owen okay
you have one child then okay well we
have three but there's only one that's
crashing all the time yeah pretty much
all right and so the other need to go
back to the class and it sounds like
they've got some growing up to do would
that be mean to say no we've told them
that we've been pretty harsh with them
we've we've told them that you know time
to grow up and play with toys and yeah
you know I love it man up and yeah we've
been pretty hard on them hold on tell me
they are I in the early 30s early
thirties yeah you know it's it's past
time thirty are they are they involved
in a good church yes that's good they
are that'll help yeah yeah they are and
they know the right thing to do is just
not doing it yeah and I think I think
you've done all the right things this
would be the way I look at it is this if
somebody's engaging in something that's
harmful to them and I give them money
I'm harming them right just the same as
if they were a drunk and wanted money in
there and I'm buying their drinks or
they're a cocaine addict and I'm giving
their money to buy their cocaine exactly
and so I love you darling but I'm not
going to finance your cocaine addiction
and and and we read my husband I agree
hundred percent I think the biggest
thing are the grandbabies they're
they're so little and we worry about
them let me ask you something when you
had babies you had three babies right
right when your kids were little were
you rich oh no are you kidding and those
kids all made it then they all got foody
they all had electricity all right there
are some times you were scared though
weren't there
oh very much I remember having 13
dollars to buy groceries for five of us
one week employment I may need to do it
we did it and she will too by the way
yes your grandbabies are gonna go hungry
right you know III there's nothing quite
like a grandmother's love but uh but
they're not going to go hungry besides
that you can tell them listen if the
babies are hungry you can bring them by
here I'll feed them
I may not thank you but I'm gonna feed
the babies now which is going to give
any of them a meal we're not worried
about that kind of stuff but the bottom
line is is these people make enough
money and they misbehave right yes and
so Joe I wouldn't give them another dime
until they straighten up okay that's
what that's what we have said and
believe that's what I just needed to
hear and I want Imagi though I everybody
runs around with this thing is that's
tough love that is not tough love that's
just love mm-hmm
yeah that is yeah leading you're leading
your toddler into the middle of the
interstate and leaving them there is not
love keeping them out of the interstate
is not tough love that's just love right
exactly and so I don't have to you know
I don't have to call it tough love
it feels tough because you're saying no
but sometimes when we're telling
somebody no it's because we love them
know is an appropriate response to
misbehavior no you can't play in the
interstate when you're three no you
can't put your finger I've got a ten
month old grandson who can crawl and
he's reaching for the light sockets all
the time and his mom is no no no
eventually there's some pain that goes
with that nose so that he didn't
electrocute his little but right then
just like light up like a cartoon one of
these days you know so you can't just
let people eat does he get mad when we
tell him no well sure the little savages
all get mad they don't they don't want
to hear No
of us want to get know but know is love
no you can't stick your finger in a
freaking light socket
no we're not going to give you money
when you're misbehaving with money
because you've never dealt with you and
it's time for you to deal with you and
that's not harsh and it's not mean you
can do it very calmly and very quietly
and very firmly with a lot of courage
because it is truly love
you